This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. On March 21st, 2022, a small crowd gathered in front of the Musso in Frank Grill on Hollywood Boulevard in Los Angeles. They weren't there for the restaurant. Instead, dozens of photographers, reporters, and Godfather fans packed in together to catch a glimpse of the ground. We now declare today Francis Ford Coppola Day in Hollywood. It was right there on one of the most famous stretches of sidewalk in the country that acclaimed film director Francis Ford Coppola received the 2715th star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame. Even if you haven't made the pilgrimage to Southern California, you can probably already
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2022年3月21日，一小群人聚集在洛杉矶好莱坞大道上的Musso & Frank烧烤店前。他们不是为了这家餐厅而来。相反，几十名摄影师、记者和《教父》的影迷挤在一起，只为一睹地面上的风采。我们现在宣布今天为好莱坞的“弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉日”。就在这条全国最著名的街道上，著名电影导演弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉获得了好莱坞星光大道的第2715颗星。即使你从未去过南加州朝圣，你可能也已经
picture what the Walk of Fame looks like. It's a 1.3 mile walkway lined with Tarotso and brass squares. Each slab spotlights a salmon pink star, and the name of a different famous celebrity deemed worthy enough to become a permanent part of Hollywood's urban fabric. Your 99PI producer this week is actor, director, and Hollywood insider, Gillian Jacobs. If our voice doesn't sound familiar, you might recognize her face from shows like Community or HBO's winning time. The walk is located on Hollywood Boulevard
能想象出星光大道是什么样子了。这是一条1.3英里长的步行道，铺满了水磨石和黄铜方块。每一块板上都镶嵌着一颗鲑鱼粉色的星星，上面刻着一位被认为有资格成为好莱坞城市肌理永久一部分的名人的名字。本周你们的99PI制作人是演员、导演兼好莱坞内部人士吉莉安·雅各布斯。如果我们的声音听起来不熟悉，你可能在《废柴联盟》或HBO的《胜利时刻》等剧中认出她的脸。这条大道位于好莱坞大道
from Gower to La Brea and continues on Vine Street from Sunset to Yucca. Back in 1960, the streets' main features were grand old movie palaces like Gromins, Chinese theater and the El Capitan. Those theaters are still there, but these days, they're surrounded by crowds of Elvis impersonators, snake wranglers, and people in Elmo costumes hoping tourists will pay to take a picture with them.
从高尔街到拉布雷亚大道，并延伸至日落大道到丝兰街之间的葡萄藤街。回到1960年，这条街的主要特色是像格劳曼中国剧院和埃尔卡皮坦剧院这样宏伟的老电影院。那些剧院依然在那里，但如今，它们被成群的猫王模仿者、玩蛇人以及穿着艾摩服装的人所包围，他们希望游客能付钱与他们合影。
A birds of 10 million people a year brave the traffic and crowds and fight over LA's skierzist resource, Parking, all just to snap a photo of a star with the name of their favorite famous person. Before working on this story, I'd never actually gone to the Hollywood Walk of Fame despite living in Los Angeles for over a decade. It might be snobbery on my part or a deep ambivalence about my own profession, but I could not understand the appeal
每年有1000万人冒着交通和拥挤，争夺洛杉矶最稀缺的资源——停车位，只为拍一张他们最喜欢的名人的星星照片。在制作这个故事之前，尽管我在洛杉矶住了十多年，但我从未真正去过好莱坞星光大道。这可能是我的势利，或者是我对自己职业的深深矛盾，但我无法理解
of looking at names embedded in the sidewalk. That is, until one day last year, when I made the rare journey to the Walgreens on sunset and fine, to buy the hypoallergenic baby detergent my dermatologist said would help with my rosacea. And I realized, I was actually stepping on a portion of the walk of fame.
看着嵌入人行道上的名字有什么吸引力。直到去年的一天，我难得去了一趟日落大道和葡萄藤街交汇处的沃尔格林药店，去买皮肤科医生说能缓解我酒糟鼻的低敏婴儿洗涤剂。然后我意识到，我实际上正踩在星光大道的一部分上。
There was the expected mixture of movie stars from the golden age of Hollywood, musicians, television stars. You know, your Merve Griffins, your James Browns, but one name made me stop in my tracks. Dorothy Arsner. If you've never heard of Dorothy Arsner before, you are not alone. Most people these days have no idea who she was, but in the history of Hollywood, Dorothy Arsner was a big deal. It went really intimate to tale.
那里有预料之中的好莱坞黄金时代的电影明星、音乐家、电视明星。你知道，像默夫·格里芬、詹姆斯·布朗这样的人，但有一个名字让我停下了脚步。多萝西·阿兹纳。如果你以前从未听说过多萝西·阿兹纳，你并不孤单。如今大多数人根本不知道她是谁，但在好莱坞历史上，多萝西·阿兹纳是个大人物。这真是个私密的故事。
Intimate to tale. Gossip. You want gossip? I'm not very good at that. Arsner was the first woman admitted to the director's guild. She made films starring Joan Crawford, Clara Boe and Lucille Ball. And even though she stopped directing in 1943, she still holds the title
私密的故事。八卦。你想要八卦吗？我不擅长那个。阿兹纳是第一位被导演工会录取的女性。她执导的电影由琼·克劳馥、克拉拉·鲍和露西尔·鲍尔主演。尽管她在1943年就停止了导演工作，但她仍然保持着
for the most American studio films directed by a woman. Which is impressive, but also super depressing, right? I had heard of her because she directed my childhood hero, Catherine Hepburn, in the film Christopher Strong. And as I've discovered more of Arseneer's work in recent years, I've also come to love her rise since of humor and her obvious skill in pulling funny, dynamic, even slightly mocking performances out of her actors. I also admire the hell out of her for being literally the only
女性执导美国电影数量最多的纪录。这令人印象深刻，但也超级令人沮丧，对吧？我听说过她，因为她执导了我童年的英雄凯瑟琳·赫本主演的电影《克里斯托弗·斯特朗》。近年来，随着我发现更多阿兹纳的作品，我也开始爱上她那敏锐的幽默感，以及她从演员身上挖掘出有趣、动态甚至略带嘲讽表演的明显技巧。我也非常钦佩她，因为在她的职业生涯中，她几乎是唯一一个
woman directing Hollywood films for much of her career. I usually announce, you know, if anyone doesn't want to work with a woman director, with me being a woman, you know, speak up now. I felt giddy seeing that star there and knowing that she's been memorialized forever. But I also felt sad too. Dorothy Star was in pretty bad shape. She was streaked with cracks and the bottom half of her travertine star legs were missing. As I stood there holding my hypoallergenic baby detergent over Dorothy Star, the thing that
执导好莱坞电影的女性。我通常会宣布，你知道，如果有人不想和女导演合作，因为我是女性，你知道，现在就说出来。看到那颗星星在那里，知道她被永远纪念，我感到一阵眩晕。但我也感到难过。多萝西的星星状况很糟糕。上面布满了裂纹，她那水磨石星星的下半部分不见了。当我站在那里，手里拿着低敏婴儿洗涤剂站在多萝西的星星上时，最让我
surprised me most is that I felt anything at all. Honestly, in my day-to-day life, I just don't think about the Hollywood Walk of Fame, but when I do, it's just another award in a town obsessed with celebrating itself. So why does this gimmicky, broken, little star make me feel things? Why does Dorothy Arson's name on the ground outside of Walgreens make me feel close to a woman I've never met? Who died before I was born? Because gimmicky or not, the walk of fame is the story of Hollywood, the film industry, and the very origin of Stardom itself in 1.3 miles
惊讶的是我竟然有任何感觉。老实说，在我的日常生活中，我根本不会去想好莱坞星光大道，但当我想到它时，它只是这个沉迷于自我庆祝的城镇里的又一个奖项。那么，为什么这颗花哨、破碎的小星星让我有感觉呢？为什么沃尔格林店外地面上多萝西·阿兹纳的名字让我觉得与一个我从未见过、在我出生前就去世的女人很亲近？因为无论是否花哨，星光大道都是好莱坞、电影工业以及明星制度起源的故事，就在这1.3英里
of sidewalk. Today, we use Hollywood as shorthand for the Bizz, and the Bizz as shorthand for the entertainment business. But there was a time when Los Angeles and the film industry weren't inextricably linked. In fact, its original home was all the way across the country in the greatest city in the world. Fort Lee, New Jersey. Like many professional actors in the US, I live in Los Angeles. And the reason I live here
的人行道上。今天，我们用“好莱坞”作为“演艺圈”的简称，用“演艺圈”作为“娱乐业”的简称。但曾几何时，洛杉矶和电影工业并没有紧密相连。事实上，它最初的家是在全国的另一端，世界上最伟大的城市——新泽西州的李堡。像美国许多职业演员一样，我住在洛杉矶。而我住在这里的原因
and not in Fort Lee is because of famous New Jersey and Thomas Edison. You do, actually. You live in Los Angeles because of Thomas Edison because he was the ass of early cinema. This is Lauren Stimer, associate professor of film and media studies at the University of South Carolina. Edison held over 1,000 patents in the U.S., including many of the patents for technologies required to make movies. And there was a problem with that. Thomas Edison was the original patent troll. Since the 1890s, Edison sued everyone
而不是住在李堡，是因为著名的新泽西人和托马斯·爱迪生。你确实是因为托马斯·爱迪生才住在洛杉矶，因为他是早期电影界的混蛋。这是南卡罗来纳大学电影与媒体研究副教授劳伦·斯蒂默。爱迪生在美国拥有1000多项专利，包括制造电影所需技术的许多专利。这带来了一个问题。托马斯·爱迪生是最初的专利流氓。自1890年代以来，爱迪生起诉了所有人
over patents, cameras, projectors, film stock. And then those companies had to pay them license fees. So if you wanted to shoot anything or screen anything, money goes to Thomas Edison. Since New Jersey was where the tech was incubated, it was also where the production offices, studio stages, talent, and by default, the entire motion picture industry was based. But Edison's stranglehold over the technology also made it more difficult, expensive, and frankly annoying for other film studios. And then over time, they realized, well, why don't we actually move far, far, far away
涉及专利、摄像机、放映机、胶片。然后那些公司必须向他支付许可费。所以如果你想拍摄或放映任何东西，钱都要流向托马斯·爱迪生。由于新泽西州是技术孵化地，它也是制作办公室、摄影棚、人才的所在地，默认情况下，整个电影工业都以此为基地。但爱迪生对技术的扼杀也使得其他电影公司的工作变得更加困难、昂贵，坦率地说，令人恼火。随着时间的推移，他们意识到，好吧，为什么我们不搬到离
from the grasp of Thomas Edison? And we'll start our own thing. It would be harder for Edison to enforce his patents from the other end of the country. And of course, the weather was better. So fledgling studios and filmmakers escaped to beautiful, distant, southern California. In the early 1900s, Hollywood hadn't yet
托马斯·爱迪生的掌控范围很远很远的地方呢？我们将开始我们自己的事业。爱迪生在全国的另一端执行他的专利会更困难。当然，天气也更好。于是，羽翼未丰的制片厂和电影制作人逃到了美丽、遥远的南加州。在1900年代初，好莱坞还没有
become the physical manifestation of the film industry. It was just another name on a map. Hollywood was its own community, and there were a lot of real estate promoters here trying to build up this community and make it something special. And so, in the motion picture industry settled, here it wasn't quite what they anticipated.
成为电影工业的物理体现。它只是地图上的另一个名字。好莱坞有它自己的社区，这里有很多房地产开发商试图建立这个社区，让它变得特别。所以，当电影工业在这里定居时，情况并不完全如他们所料。
This is Laurent Goobler, former president of the Hollywood Chamber of Commerce, which is the entity that oversees the walk of fame. Hollywood was founded in 1887 when Harvey Wilcox and his wife, Deiida, registered his 160 acres of land with the Los Angeles County Recorder's office. These acres, just south of what is now known as the Hollywood Hills, were filled with apricots and fig trees. And for film studios looking for open space to build an industry on, it must have looked like heaven. But the Wilcox's were the opposite of showbiz people.
这是好莱坞商会前主席劳伦·古布勒，该机构负责监督星光大道。好莱坞成立于1887年，当时哈维·威尔科克斯和他的妻子戴伊达在洛杉矶县记录员办公室注册了他那160英亩的土地。这些英亩土地位于现在被称为好莱坞山以南的地方，种满了杏树和无花果树。对于寻找开放空间来建立工业的电影制片厂来说，这一定看起来像天堂。但威尔科克斯夫妇与演艺圈人士截然不同。
They were religious tea tollers who envisioned their new community as a Christian utopia, or vice, would be banned. Hollywood was a very conservatively straight-laced community. And stars and celebrities at that time were not looked upon favorably. In fact, they had signs in the part of the buildings saying, no actors and no animals allowed. So that was the original attitude towards actors back in the early 20th century. But the Wilcox's couldn't keep actors out for long. By 1910, Hollywood went from being its own municipality to an incorporated district of Los Angeles.
他们是虔诚的禁酒主义者，设想他们的新社区是一个基督教乌托邦，在那里恶习将被禁止。好莱坞是一个非常保守、循规蹈矩的社区。当时的明星和名人并不被看好。事实上，他们在建筑的一部分贴了告示，写着“禁止演员和动物入内”。这就是20世纪初对演员的最初态度。但威尔科克斯夫妇无法长期将演员拒之门外。到1910年，好莱坞从一个独立的城市变成了洛杉矶的一个合并区。
And by 1911, the very first of many film studios in the area were built. Hollywood would be the new home of the big, bad movie business. Oh, it was very down market. It was very shady stuff for the movies. Typer is a film critic and the author of Gods Like Us on Movie Start-Umm and Modern Fame. He says that in the nascent years of the movie industry, the very idea of a monument to film actors like the Walk of Fame would have been unfathomable. You know, in the earliest days of movies, they didn't even call it acting.
到1911年，该地区许多电影制片厂中的第一家建成了。好莱坞将成为这个庞大、糟糕的电影生意的新家。哦，它非常低端。电影是非常阴暗的东西。泰珀是一位电影评论家，也是《像我们一样的神：关于电影明星和现代名声》的作者。他说，在电影工业的萌芽时期，像星光大道这样为电影演员建立纪念碑的想法是不可想象的。你知道，在电影的最早期，他们甚至不称之为表演。
They used all these different verbs to describe what was going on, shaming, posing, playing, but never acting. It was just sort of being yourself in front of the camera. So whatever it was, it wasn't acting. It was just sort of being yourself in front of the camera. So whatever it was, it wasn't acting. Movies were viewed as a novelty at the time. Unlike today's films, Erleys and Mutt rarely had narrative plots. They were mostly just snippets of life captured on camera. Films were also silent, with no dialogue to memorize. So actors were pretty far away from Thespians residing Iambic pentameter on stage. And shockingly to this SAG member,
他们用各种不同的动词来描述正在发生的事情，比如“羞辱”、“摆姿势”、“玩耍”，但从不叫“表演”。这只是在镜头前做你自己。所以无论它是什么，它都不是表演。这只是在镜头前做你自己。所以无论它是什么，它都不是表演。电影在当时被视为一种新奇事物。与今天的电影不同，早期的电影很少有叙事剧情。它们大多只是镜头捕捉到的生活片段。电影也是无声的，没有台词需要背诵。所以演员与舞台上朗诵抑扬格五音步的戏剧演员相去甚远。而且令这位演员工会成员震惊的是，
performers weren't even credited, mostly because movie studios didn't want people to care about the actors. Call Lemley, you founded Universal. They all realized that as soon as you started naming an actor by name and promoting them, you would have to pay them more money. So for the first
表演者甚至没有署名，主要是因为电影公司不希望人们关心演员。卡尔·莱姆勒，你创立了环球影业。他们都意识到，一旦你开始用名字命名演员并推广他们，你就必须付给他们更多的钱。所以前
15 years of the film industry actors were not named. You just got the title, you got the company that made the film in that way, see it? But during the first decade of the 20th century the number of small movie theaters and Nickelodeon's skyrocketed across the country Production companies rushed to produce enough content to meet the growing need for new films. Many studios relied on factory-style methods to create more movies, and would often cast the same group of actors
15年的电影工业中，演员没有名字。你只得到片名，得到制作电影的公司，就这样，明白吗？但在20世纪的第一个十年里，全国各地的小电影院和镍币影院数量激增。制作公司竞相生产足够的内容以满足对新电影日益增长的需求。许多制片厂依靠工厂式的方法来制作更多的电影，并且为了实用起见，经常会使用同一群演员
over and over for the sake of practicality. And because audiences were seeing the same actors over and over again, viewers were becoming attached to the faces they were seeing on screen. One of the things I found fascinating when I was researching my book was how crazy people went to find out the identity of these people. So people would write to the film companies to the biograph girl or the girl with the curls or whatever they named them. And the letters that with a girl, so whatever they named them. And the letters that come up in the researcher
一遍又一遍。因为观众一遍又一遍地看到同样的演员，观众开始对他们在银幕上看到的脸产生依恋。我在研究我的书时发现的一件令人着迷的事情是，人们为了找出这些人的身份有多疯狂。所以人们会写信给电影公司，给“传记女孩”或“卷发女孩”或任何他们给他们起的名字。而那些出现在研究中的信件
are really kind of touching and sad and indicative of where we were going as a culture. People saying, please tell me your name. I won't tell anybody else, but please tell me your name. And just this yearning that comes across, and it's a new kind of yearning. Soon, movie studios had no choice but to yield to their audiences demands and start identifying and then promoting their stars.
真的让人感到触动和悲伤，也预示了我们作为一个文化正在走向何方。人们说，请告诉我你的名字。我不会告诉别人的，但请告诉我你的名字。这种渴望感油然而生，这是一种新的渴望。很快，电影公司别无选择，只能屈服于观众的需求，开始识别并推广他们的明星。
Once you name one star, you got a name of all. And that's right there is where the star system is born. You might understandably think that with all this new fame and prestige, all this collective yearning, that Hollywood actors would finally come into their power, but it didn't quite work out that way. Instead, executives like Carl Lemley realized that Stardom was a commodity that could be manufactured, controlled, and profited from. Studio's tied up actors in exclusive contracts,
一旦你命名了一个明星，你就得命名所有人。而这正是明星制度诞生的地方。你可能会理所当然地认为，随着所有这些新的名声和威望，所有这些集体的渴望，好莱坞演员最终会获得权力，但事情并没有那样发展。相反，像卡尔·莱姆勒这样的高管意识到，明星地位是一种可以被制造、控制并从中获利的商品。制片厂用独家合同束缚演员，
which meant they could only work for that particular studio. They had nearly complete control over their stars. So you had not just to go where they wanted you to go, but you had to be photographed and be photographed how they wanted you to be photographed. So they would tell you to go to Mooseone Franks, and and they'll be some photographers outside and you're going to have a dinner inside and magically the photographers will find their way inside to a private restaurant. Movie studios understood how these public spaces could be used to generate even more star power.
这意味着他们只能为那个特定的制片厂工作。他们对他们的明星拥有几乎完全的控制权。所以你不仅要按照他们想要你去的地方去，你还必须被拍照，并且按照他们想要你被拍照的方式被拍照。所以他们会告诉你去Musso & Franks，外面会有一些摄影师，你在里面吃晚餐，神奇的是摄影师会找到进入私人餐厅的路。电影公司明白这些公共空间如何被用来产生更多的明星力量。
So they started exerting control not only over which pictures the stars acted in, but where they went at night, and with whom. If you were not romantically involved with anyone at that time, they would actually craft a narrative in which you were dating some other celebrity at the studio or newcomer at the studio that they wanted to promote to help their career. Back then, an appearance at a restaurant like the Brown Derby guaranteed a write-up. Rival gossip columnist Luwela Parsons and Hedahopper were permanent fixtures inside. It generated publicity for the actors and the restaurants, and let fans know where to
所以他们开始不仅控制明星出演哪些电影，还控制他们晚上去哪里，和谁在一起。如果你当时没有和任何人谈恋爱，他们实际上会编造一个叙事，说你正在和制片厂里的其他名人或他们想要推广的新人约会，以帮助他们的职业生涯。那时，在像棕色德比这样的餐厅露面保证会有报道。竞争对手八卦专栏作家卢埃拉·帕森斯和海达·霍珀是里面的常客。这为演员和餐厅带来了宣传，并让粉丝们知道如果他们想亲自见到明星该去哪里。
go if they wanted to see stars in person. Meanwhile, the neighborhood of Hollywood, which not long before had its no actors, no animals rule, quickly capitalized on the film industry and its celebrity status. If Detroit had its cars, then Hollywood had its stars. This is the city below, looks like any others, following the tropolis. Yet this one is different. Its fame has spread to the four corners of the earth. Its name is known to practically every man, woman, and child in the universe.
与此同时，不久前还有“禁止演员、禁止动物”规则的好莱坞社区，迅速利用了电影工业及其名人地位。如果底特律有汽车，那么好莱坞就有明星。这是下面的城市，看起来像其他任何城市，追随大都市。然而这个是不同的。它的名声已经传到了地球的四个角落。它的名字几乎被宇宙中的每一个男人、女人和孩子所知。
Or this is Abelus Hollywood. The press actually really pushed both the idea of the star and the idea of Hollywood is this glamorous identifiable location. And it helps cement this idea that Hollywood itself was such a glamorous area. Despite its reputation today, the truth is that not many movies are actually filmed in Hollywood. And this was true even back in the day. Of the five big film studios of the time, MGM, Warner Brothers, Paramount, Fox, and RKO, most were located in other parts of Los Angeles, not Hollywood.
或者这就是好莱坞。媒体实际上确实推动了明星的概念和好莱坞作为这个迷人、可识别地点的概念。这有助于巩固好莱坞本身就是一个迷人地区的想法。尽管它今天享有盛誉，但事实是，实际上在好莱坞拍摄的电影并不多。即使在过去也是如此。在当时五大电影制片厂中，米高梅、华纳兄弟、派拉蒙、福克斯和雷电华，大多数都位于洛杉矶的其他地区，而不是好莱坞。
Municipally, it is its own thing, and I think it's always existed parallel to the film industry, sometimes almost as a parasite of the film industry. But movie makers understood the power of branding, and so the name Hollywood became synonymous with entertainment. One of the most interesting aspects of Hollywood is the motion picture industry. This vast empire is also a potent factor in the economic life of Southern California. Its studios employ thousands of workers, electricians, carpenter, painters, seamstresses, artists, artisans of every conceivable time. Throughout the 1930s, MGM Studios had actors like Clark Gable and Judy Garland on their
从市政上讲，它有自己的东西，我认为它一直与电影工业平行存在，有时几乎是电影工业的寄生虫。但电影制作人理解品牌的力量，所以“好莱坞”这个名字成了娱乐的代名词。好莱坞最有趣的方面之一是电影工业。这个庞大的帝国也是南加州经济生活中的一个有力因素。它的制片厂雇佣了成千上万的工人，电工、木匠、油漆工、裁缝、艺术家、各种可以想象的工匠。在整个1930年代，米高梅制片厂拥有像克拉克·盖博和朱迪·加兰这样的演员在他们的
roster. Dorothy Arsner, the director who star I saw in the walk of fame, was at the peak of her career. She worked extensively with Paramount Studios where she directed 11 features in five years. The movie industry was one of the biggest businesses in the world, and as it reached the height of its power, film became the economic lifeblood of Los Angeles. Nothing could stop Hollywood. Nothing except for the Supreme Court.
名单上。我在星光大道上看到星星的导演多萝西·阿兹纳正处于她职业生涯的巅峰。她与派拉蒙影业广泛合作，在那里她五年内执导了11部故事片。电影工业是世界上最大的企业之一，当它达到权力的顶峰时，电影成为了洛杉矶的经济命脉。没有什么能阻止好莱坞。除了最高法院。
So the Paramount Decision 48 it affected all of the major studios. The Paramount Decision was a landmark antitrust ruling that went after the big five movie studios who dominated Hollywood. That's the number one thing that destabilized the industry and that was kind of the various load of the industry and their power. Basically the big five had a powerful monopoly
所以1948年的派拉蒙判决影响了所有主要制片厂。派拉蒙判决是一项具有里程碑意义的反垄断裁决，针对的是主宰好莱坞的五大电影制片厂。这是破坏该行业稳定的第一件事，也是该行业及其权力的各种负担。基本上，五大巨头拥有强大的垄断地位
over the entire motion picture industry. They controlled everything from the production of films right down to the theaters that screened them. If a studio owned a movie theater, it could shut out its competition by refusing to play any film from a rival company. The 1948 rule put an end to that, making studios give up control of their movie theaters
在整个电影工业中。他们控制着从电影制作到放映电影的影院的一切。如果一家制片厂拥有一家电影院，它可以通过拒绝播放任何竞争对手公司的电影来排挤竞争对手。1948年的裁决结束了这一点，迫使制片厂放弃对电影院的控制权
and sell them to independent companies, which was great for competition, but bad for the system Hollywood had been built on. On top of that, in the late 40s and early 50s, Americans were flocking to newly constructed suburbs far away from the city centers where movie palaces were located, ticket sales plummeted. The Hollywood film industry was suffering and with it, the District of Hollywood. Retail had gone into a state of decline because people weren't coming over the hill to shop like they once did.
并将它们卖给独立公司，这对竞争很有利，但对好莱坞建立的体系却很糟糕。最重要的是，在40年代末和50年代初，美国人纷纷涌向远离电影院所在市中心的新建郊区，门票销售暴跌。好莱坞电影工业正在受苦，好莱坞区也随之受苦。零售业陷入了衰退，因为人们不像以前那样翻山越岭来购物了。
Laurent Goobler says that residents who fled over the hill for the San Fernando Valley suburbs weren't just ditching a night out at the picture palace. They were ditching the entire local economy. It seemed as though the industry and the neighborhood were in crisis. So in 1953, in response to declining revenue and a distinct lack of good old Hollywood oomph, a man named E. M. Stewart, who was the volunteer president of the Chamber of Commerce Commerce came up with an idea. It was a plan to harken back to the old, glorious days of Highwood. He said the tourists come here looking for stars and are disappointed, so let's give them
劳伦·古布勒说，那些翻山越岭逃往圣费尔南多谷郊区的居民不仅仅是放弃了在电影院度过的夜晚。他们放弃了整个当地经济。似乎工业和社区都陷入了危机。因此，在1953年，为了应对收入下降和缺乏好的老式好莱坞活力，一位名叫E.M.斯图尔特的人，他是商会的志愿者主席，想出了一个主意。这是一个回归好莱坞辉煌旧日时光的计划。他说游客来这里寻找明星却感到失望，所以让我们给他们
stars. The chamber announced an oppressed release that they were proposing an attraction that would maintain the glory of a community whose name means glamour and excitement in the four corners of the world, the Walk of a community whose name means glamour and excitement in the four corners of the world, the walk of fame. The idea would be to take the ethereal stars from the screen and place them into the ground where anyone could visit them. Instead of hoping, and then failing, to bump into William Holden at the Brown Derby, you
星星。商会发布了一份新闻稿，提议建立一个景点，以保持一个社区的荣耀，这个社区的名字在世界四个角落意味着魅力和兴奋，星光大道。这个想法是将银幕上空灵的星星带下来，放入地面，任何人都可以参观。与其希望并最终失败地在棕色德比餐厅偶遇威廉·霍尔顿，你
can at least know that you'll have a small piece of him along Hollywood in Vine, and then as you're strolling along to take a picture of Humphrey Bogart or Claude Atkold Bear Star, oh, hey, maybe you'll pop into Woolworth to buy a new handbag or duck into Mousseau and Frank's for a steak lunch. Very subtle. So when they were designing the stars, what they were actually going to look like, there was a lot of discussion. Knowing quite knows where the original idea came from,
至少可以知道你会在好莱坞和葡萄藤街沿线拥有他的一小部分，然后当你漫步去拍一张汉弗莱·鲍嘉或克劳黛·考尔白的星星照片时，哦，嘿，也许你会跳进伍尔沃斯买个新手提包，或者溜进Musso & Frank吃顿牛排午餐。非常微妙。所以当他们设计星星时，它们实际上会是什么样子，有很多讨论。没人确切知道最初的想法来自哪里，
but Laurent believes the inspiration for the design of the walk came from the ceiling of the dining room in the Hollywood hotel. A lot of celebrities come out there and in their dining room on the ceiling, they had stars with the names of celebrities, and if you look at those stars, they are very similar to what ended up in the ground. The Chamber of Commerce created four committees with experts in four separate categories, motion pictures, television, audio recording, and radio. The first members of the motion picture committee included industry giants, Cecil B. DeMille, Samuel Goldwyn, and Walt Disney. They combed through thousands of names
但劳伦认为星光大道设计的灵感来自好莱坞酒店餐厅的天花板。很多名人都去那里，在他们的餐厅天花板上，他们有刻着名人名字的星星，如果你看那些星星，它们与最终出现在地面上的非常相似。商会成立了四个委员会，由四个不同类别的专家组成：电影、电视、音频录制和广播。电影委员会的第一批成员包括行业巨头塞西尔·B·德米尔、塞缪尔·戈德温和华特·迪士尼。他们梳理了成千上万的名字
dating back to the earliest days of Hollywood in order to decide who deserved to be honored on the brand new Walk of Fame. At this time, there was a kind of cosmic shift taking place. By the 1950s and 60s, the actors who had inspired that new kind of yearning were changing. While the town and the film business were still relatively young, the movie stars fueling the industry were not. The classic stars were getting old. And stars aren't supposed to get old. And what happens when a star gets old? We hadn't really hadn't come to grips with that as a culture. But you get into the post-war era and cables getting old
追溯到好莱坞的最早时期，以决定谁有资格在全新的星光大道上获得荣誉。此时，发生了一种宇宙级的转变。到了1950年代和60年代，那些激发了那种新渴望的演员正在发生变化。虽然城镇和电影生意还相对年轻，但推动该行业的电影明星却不是。经典的明星正在变老。而明星是不应该变老的。当明星变老时会发生什么？作为一个文化，我们还没有真正解决这个问题。但你进入战后时代，盖博正在变老
and Crawfords getting old and all these things are just changing. A permanent ode to the great stars that made Hollywood itself great seemed like a very appropriate tribute. The walk debuted with a sort of soft open with the unveiling of eight stars. Joanne Woodward, Olive Borden, Ronald Coleman, Louise Fazenda, Preston Foster, Bert Langcaster,
克劳馥正在变老，所有这些事情都在改变。对使好莱坞本身变得伟大的伟大明星的永久颂歌似乎是一个非常恰当的致敬。星光大道以一种软开幕的方式首次亮相，揭幕了八颗星星。琼·伍德沃德、奥利弗·博登、罗纳德·科尔曼、路易丝·法森达、普雷斯顿·福斯特、伯特·兰卡斯特、
Edward Sedwick, Ernest Torrance, and me Roman Mars. Sorry, force-fapet. And in 1961, after years of debate over where it would go and who would be honored, if the color scheme would clash with the neighborhood, and if Charlie Chaplin was indeed a communist, the walk was finally installed. They put in 1,500 stars all at once to create an instant tourist attraction. The Chamber of Commerce wanted to acknowledge that this would be a living monument, so it left about 500 stars blank as placeholders for future recipients. This was a pragmatic move because, let's be honest, of those first eight names unveiled on the Walk of Fame,
爱德华·塞奇威克、欧内斯特·托伦斯，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。抱歉，强行加入。1961年，经过多年关于它应该去哪里、谁应该被授予荣誉、配色方案是否会与社区冲突、查理·卓别林是否确实是共产主义者的辩论后，星光大道终于安装完毕。他们一次性安装了1500颗星星，以创造一个即时的旅游景点。商会想承认这将是一个活的纪念碑，所以它留下了大约500颗空白的星星作为未来获奖者的占位符。这是一个务实的举动，因为说实话，在星光大道上揭幕的那最初八个名字中，
chances are you didn't recognize most if any of them. The chamber knew that the industry was fickle, that people would eventually forget about their old favorites and move on to the next big star in line, whether that was Farah Fawcett or Frances Ford Coppola. It's a permanent memorial dedicated to a fleeting concept, fame. Although it began as a ploy to generate business, the walk of fame ended up tapping into that intimate connection people feel for their favorite performer. The same one that had fans writing to movie studios
你很可能认不出其中大多数人，如果不是全部的话。商会知道这个行业是反复无常的，人们最终会忘记他们旧日的宠儿，转而追随下一个排队的大明星，无论是法拉·福塞特还是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉。这是一个致力于一个短暂概念——名声——的永久纪念碑。虽然它最初是一个为了创造商业的策略，但星光大道最终触及了人们对自己最喜欢的表演者所感受到的那种亲密联系。那种在电影早期
in the early days of cinema begging to learn the names of the girl with the curls or the biograph girl. The walk of fame allows people to feel that they are in the presence of in these sort of privy to whatever star dust, whatever magic these people had. There's that gulf between us and them. And there are very few places that bridge it with physicality. And that is the story of how the walk of fame saved Hollywood.
让粉丝写信给电影公司，乞求知道“卷发女孩”或“传记女孩”名字的联系。星光大道让人们觉得他们就在这些人的面前，或者说分享了这些人所拥有的任何星尘、任何魔力。我们和他们之间存在着那道鸿沟。而很少有地方能用物理性来弥合它。这就是星光大道如何拯救好莱坞的故事。
So things really start to go downhill in the 1960s and 70s between the 60s and the 80s. Yeah, it was never going to be that easy. Despite the Chamber of Commerce's best efforts, the neighborhood kept declining. This was something that was happening to urban areas all over post-war America. But contrasted to its glory days, the decay of Hollywood Boulevard felt extra bleak. Hollywood Boulevard becomes a place where you find a lot of, what can I call them? Cheap stores, stores for $5, $5, really, really cheaply made souvenirs. And those picture
所以事情在1960年代和70年代真的开始走下坡路了，在60年代到80年代之间。是的，这永远不会那么容易。尽管商会尽了最大努力，社区还是不断衰落。这是战后美国各地城市地区都在发生的事情。但与它的辉煌岁月相比，好莱坞大道的衰败显得格外凄凉。好莱坞大道变成了一个你会发现很多，我该怎么称呼它们？廉价商店，5美元的商店，真的，真的制作廉价的纪念品。而那些电影
palaces, like in the 1960s and 70s, if they're still around, they're showing porn. There was a period in the late 70s and early 80s when it was difficult to find celebrities who would accept stars. The problem was Hollywood was going downhill economically and physically and it was becoming kind of rough out there on the sidewalks and a lot of celebrities were reluctant to accept stars at that time. The wrong Googler says that the walk of fame itself was never actually in any danger of disappearing even as the urban area around it deteriorated in part because of the ways the walk has had to evolve over the years.
宫殿，就像在1960年代和70年代，如果它们还在的话，它们在放映色情片。在70年代末和80年代初有一段时间，很难找到愿意接受星星的名人。问题是好莱坞在经济和物理上都在走下坡路，人行道上变得有点粗糙，很多名人在那个时候不愿意接受星星。劳伦·古布勒说，星光大道本身从未真正面临消失的危险，即使它周围的城市区域恶化，部分原因是星光大道多年来必须进化的方式。
Since it was first installed, the Chamber of Commerce has made a number of changes to its process. It added additional categories to honor, expanded the actual area of the walk, and began hosting unveiling ceremonies for each new star installed. So the celebrity receiving the star actually has to show up in order to get one. And in the 1980s, a radio and television personality named Johnny Grant stepped onto the scene to try and shake things up. Johnny was the world's greatest promoter.
自首次安装以来，商会对其流程进行了一些更改。它增加了额外的荣誉类别，扩大了星光大道的实际区域，并开始为每一颗新安装的星星举办揭幕仪式。所以接受星星的名人实际上必须露面才能获得一颗。在1980年代，一位名叫约翰尼·格兰特的广播和电视名人走上舞台，试图改变现状。约翰尼是世界上最伟大的推广者。
And when he got his star, he got involved in the ceremony. He arranged for a military flyover and a brass band and the committee that put on the Wacafame was so impressed with what he did for his own ceremony that they said, hey, Johnny, how would you like to chair the walk of fame? And he immediately jumped at the opportunity and really is probably the person most responsible for what the walk of fame has become today. But one of the most important changes to the process was instigating a fee in order to receive a star on the walk of fame.
当他获得他的星星时，他参与了仪式。他安排了军事飞行表演和铜管乐队，举办星光大道的委员会对他为自己的仪式所做的事情印象深刻，以至于他们说，嘿，约翰尼，你想担任星光大道的主席吗？他立即抓住了这个机会，确实可能是对星光大道今天所成为的样子负有最大责任的人。但流程中最重要的变化之一是引入了获得星光大道星星的费用。
In 1980, this started at $2,500 to help pay for installation, maintenance, and the unveiling ceremony. But by 2022, it's ballooned to $55,000. In most cases, a studio or sponsor will foot the bill because it's great publicity. There's a whole nomination process involved, so it's not like you can just shell out fifty five thousand dollars and buy yourself a star but the price tag as well as how that money is spent has been a point of criticism for the walk over the years. Well for me the significance is that you only get a star on the Hollywood Boulevard if you're willing to pay for it or or someone who's trying to get publicity
1980年，这笔费用从2500美元开始，用于帮助支付安装、维护和揭幕仪式的费用。但到2022年，它已经膨胀到55000美元。在大多数情况下，制片厂或赞助商会支付这笔费用，因为这是一种很好的宣传。这涉及整个提名过程，所以并不是说你可以随便掏出55000美元给自己买一颗星星，但价格标签以及这笔钱的支出方式多年来一直是星光大道受到批评的一点。好吧，对我来说，意义在于只有当你愿意支付费用，或者试图为即将上映的电影获得宣传的人支付费用时，你才能在好莱坞大道上获得一颗星星，这就是大多数星星被放置在那里的方式。
for a film coming out pays for it, which is how most of them get put there. This is Walk of Fame star recipient, Frances Ford Coppola. Wait, you know Frances Ford Coppola? I know a guy who knows a guy. If you weren't aware, Coppola is the director of the Godfather Trilogy, Apocalypse Now, and a personal favorite of mine, the conversation. Even though his career spans decades,
这是星光大道获奖者，弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉。等等，你认识弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉？我认识一个认识某人的人。如果你不知道，科波拉是《教父》三部曲、《现代启示录》的导演，也是我个人的最爱，《对话》。尽管他的职业生涯跨越了几十年，
he says he didn't receive his star until early 2022 because of the hefty price. Usually my films were produced by myself and we did not spend money and PR in grandizing people like myself. But now with the 50th anniversary of the Godfather Paramount is willing to treat me to that. And certainly, there are many people on that walk of fame that I am humbly proud to be in their company.
他说他直到2022年初才收到他的星星，因为价格昂贵。通常我的电影是由我自己制作的，我们不会花钱在像我这样的人身上进行公关宣传。但现在随着《教父》50周年纪念，派拉蒙愿意为我支付这笔费用。当然，星光大道上有许多人，我很谦卑地为能与他们为伍而感到自豪。
One of them is Miss Arsner. Miss Arsner, as in Dorothy Arsner, the film director who's broken star on the walk of fame first got me interested in this story. After Arsner retired from directing, she taught film at UCLA, where one of her students was actually a young Francis Ford Coppola.
其中之一是阿兹纳小姐。阿兹纳小姐，是指多萝西·阿兹纳，那位在星光大道上破碎的星星让我第一次对这个故事产生兴趣的电影导演。阿兹纳从导演岗位退休后，她在加州大学洛杉矶分校教电影，她的学生中实际上有一位年轻的弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉。
Well, Miss Arsner was a wonderful teacher. She really made us feel as if she cared for us. And aside from that, she was a movie pioneer. She was one of the people who created this cinema. Arsner had a reputation for being a director with an eye for New Talent. She was able to help craft on-screen personas for new actors and mold them into stars.
嗯，阿兹纳小姐是一位出色的老师。她真的让我们觉得她关心我们。除此之外，她还是一位电影先驱。她是创造这个电影的人之一。阿兹纳以是一位有眼光发现新人才的导演而闻名。她能够帮助为新演员塑造银幕形象，并将他们塑造成明星。
She was always coming up with little tidbits like that, to help craft on-screen personas for new actors and mold them into stars. She was always coming up with little tidbits like that, little pointers, and of course the most significant one that the director should always sit at the same place next to the camera, not only because that's the best view, but also it was so the actors would see that you're there and because they're doing it for you and if you're back away in some place where there are television monitors, the actors can't see who they're doing it for. Arsenal also had a successful career as a film editor before she began
她总是想出这样的小窍门，来帮助为新演员塑造银幕形象，并将他们塑造成明星。她总是想出这样的小窍门，小指针，当然最重要的一点是导演应该总是坐在摄像机旁边的同一个地方，不仅因为那是最好的视角，而且是因为这样演员会看到你在那里，因为他们是为你而做的，如果你躲在某个有电视监视器的地方，演员就看不到他们是为谁而做的。阿兹纳在开始之前也有过成功的电影剪辑师生涯
directing. Coppola says that she showed him some important directorial tips from back when you physically cut and paste film negatives, and you had to use your arm to measure the length of a scene. I remember she told me once that and demonstrating that one arm length for a kiss was a long sexy kiss, but two arm lengths was a really a passionate kiss, and three Arnold links was a very sexy kiss. And on top of that, Arsene made some pretty amazing technological contributions to filmmaking.
执导。科波拉说，她向他展示了一些重要的导演技巧，那是从你物理上剪切和粘贴电影底片的时候开始的，你必须用你的手臂来测量场景的长度。我记得她有一次告诉我，演示说一个手臂长度的吻是一个长而性感的吻，但两个手臂长度是一个非常热情的吻，三个手臂长度是一个非常性感的吻。最重要的是，阿兹纳对电影制作做出了一些非常惊人的技术贡献。
She's credited with inventing the prototype for the very first boom mic. Here she is talking about how she came up with the idea in order to let the actress Clara Bow move around freely on set. They'd hang the mic and Clara Bow would have to say what she had to say, and then be silent until she got over here if she moved. And it wasn't many days till I said to the prop man, do you have a fish pole?
她被认为是发明了第一个吊杆麦克风的原型。这是她在谈论她是如何想出这个主意，以便让女演员克拉拉·鲍在片场自由走动。他们会挂起麦克风，克拉拉·鲍必须说她必须说的话，然后保持沉默，直到她移动到这里。没过几天，我就对道具师说，你有钓鱼竿吗？
And he said, yes, and I said, bring it tomorrow and a ladder and hang that thing on it. And when Clara moves, you move that with it. It might not be a microphone tape to a fishing pole anymore, but the boom is a piece of equipment that's still essential on film sets today. In 1943, Dorothy Arsner retired from the film industry. It was probably much earlier in her career than she anticipated. I got pneumonia on the last picture I made, which it took me some time to get over and I didn't feel strong.
他说，有，我说，明天带过来，再带个梯子，把那个东西挂在上面。当克拉拉移动时，你跟着它移动。它可能不再是贴在钓鱼竿上的麦克风了，但吊杆是今天电影片场仍然必不可少的设备。1943年，多萝西·阿兹纳从电影工业退休。这可能比她预期的职业生涯要早得多。我在我拍的最后一部电影中得了肺炎，我花了一些时间才恢复过来，我感觉不强壮。
You have to be strong to be a director to stand up to the end. Health issues aside, she was also a female film director and a lesbian. At this point, sexism and homophobia and Hollywood were squeezing out people like her. Arzuna directed her last Hollywood film at age 46. The fact that someone has a star on the walk of fame means that they achieved a level of renown and acclaimed so immense that the Chamber of Commerce thought that the mere sight of their name would entice tourists to the area. But the reality is that the industry and the public have a short memory when it
你必须强壮才能成为一名导演，才能坚持到底。健康问题暂且不论，她还是一位女性电影导演和女同性恋者。在这一点上，好莱坞的性别歧视和恐同症正在排挤像她这样的人。阿兹纳在46岁时执导了她的最后一部好莱坞电影。一个人在星光大道上有星星意味着他们达到了如此巨大的名声和赞誉，以至于商会认为仅仅看到他们的名字就会吸引游客到该地区。但现实是，工业和公众在
comes to people like Dorothy Arsner. And many of the names on the sidewalk that were once a draw have faded into obscurity. Thank you. You're welcome. You read? I don't know. No, thank you. Today Hollywood Boulevard isn't better shape, but it wasn't all because of the walk of fame. In the early 2000s, the city invested millions of dollars of public and private money to build
对待像多萝西·阿兹纳这样的人时记忆力很短。人行道上许多曾经吸引人的名字已经淡出人们的视野。谢谢。不客气。你读了吗？我不知道。不，谢谢。今天好莱坞大道状况较好，但这并不全是星光大道的功劳。在2000年代初，该市投入了数百万美元的公共和私人资金来建设
up Hollywood and Highland into a commercial district, equipped with a shopping center and luxury hotel. Jimmy Kimmel does film there, and Hollywood has hosted the Academy Awards since 2001, except for in 2021 because of the pandemic. But the general area has undergone a sort of time squareification where it's, you know, fine, I guess. There's a lot of space, a lot of retail space that's taken up by, hmm, why won't I call them?
好莱坞和高地成为一个商业区，配备了购物中心和豪华酒店。吉米·坎摩尔在那里拍摄电影，好莱坞自2001年以来一直举办奥斯卡颁奖典礼，除了2021年因为疫情。但整个地区经历了一种“时代广场化”，就是，你知道，还可以吧。有很多空间，很多零售空间被，嗯，我该怎么称呼它们？
They're like, they're designed to appeal to anyone who's there. They're really just tourist traps. And despite the somewhat renewed glamour, you are very, very, very unlikely to see a celebrity walking down the walk of fame. There is a man with two snakes. There is a man with two snakes. I'm very afraid.
它们的设计是为了吸引那里的任何人。它们真的只是旅游陷阱。尽管魅力有所恢复，但你非常、非常、非常不可能看到名人在星光大道上行走。有一个带着两条蛇的男人。有一个带着两条蛇的男人。我非常害怕。
I am walking away. There are people paying to have the man put snakes on them. I think the unintended irony of the walk of fame is that it was a group of business owners, not the film industry itself, that gave those stars a permanent place to be memorialized. And for underappreciated pioneers like Dorothy Arzner, her star on the walk of fame remains the greatest public tribute to her life and career, even if it is missing a few pieces. You remarked how the Hollywood boulevard star with her name on it was rather old and worn. Here's Frances Ford Coppola again. To me that is a badge of honor because it shows how long her name was enshrined in that way.
我正要走开。有些人花钱让人把蛇放在他们身上。我认为星光大道无意中的讽刺在于，是商业业主群体，而不是电影产业本身，赋予了这些星星一个被永久纪念的地方。对于像多萝西·阿兹纳这样被低估的先驱来说，她在星光大道上的星星仍然是对她一生和职业生涯最伟大的公众致敬，即使它缺失了一些部分。你提到她名字的好莱坞大道星星相当陈旧和磨损。这是弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉再次谈到这一点。对我来说，那是一种荣誉勋章，因为它展示了她的名字以这种方式被铭记了多久。
And in terms of Miss Arthur's legacy, of course, the first way that is preserved by the many movies she worked on. Frances Ford Coppola probably has the healthier perspective on this matter. But I still felt bummed about Dorothy Star. And because the Chamber of Commerce maintains the walk of fame, I couldn't help
就阿瑟小姐的遗产而言，当然，第一种保存方式是她参与的许多电影。弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉在这个问题上可能有更健康的视角。但我仍然对多萝西的星星感到沮丧。而且因为商会负责维护星光大道，我忍不住
but raise the issue of her missing star legs when I was talking with Laurent Goobler. Yeah, ascending if there's a star that needs repairs of somebody sends an email to the chamber, uh, info at Hollywood Chamber, not net will pass it on to the historic trust. So if there's one that you think needs to need some attention, just let us know. Miss Arzner is missing her bottom legs, her bottom star legs. Oh, the Traso's missing? Yeah.
在和劳伦·古布勒交谈时提出了她星星底部缺失的问题。是的，如果有一颗星星需要维修，有人给商会发电子邮件，呃，info at Hollywood Chamber dot net 会把它转给历史信托基金。所以如果你认为哪一颗星星需要关注，请告诉我们。阿兹纳小姐的底部缺失了，她星星的底部。哦，水磨石缺失了？是的。
Okay. Let me make a note. She's near the wall green. I'm like, what if I'm not? Near the wall green? She's across the street from the wall greens. Really? Okay.
好的。让我记下来。她在华格林附近。我在想，如果我不在华格林附近怎么办？她在华格林街对面。真的吗？好的。
A few months ago, I took a stroll over to North Fine to pick up more detergent, and not only was the wall green's gone, but I was horrified to see the Dorothy star was somehow in worse shape. The bottom of her cracked herosso had been filled in with black asphalt by the city, which was something that LaRon warned could happen if there was a tripping hazard. I don't know if there's any point to the walk of fame or fame or Hollywood or any of this business that I've chosen. Some days when I think of Dorothy's star, it just feels like a symbol of how quickly Hollywood forgets. There are more than 2700
几个月前，我漫步到北法恩去买更多的洗涤剂，不仅华格林不见了，而且我惊恐地发现多萝西的星星状况更糟了。她破裂的水磨石底部被市政当局填上了黑色沥青，这是劳伦警告过如果存在绊倒危险可能会发生的事情。我不知道我所选择的星光大道、名声、好莱坞或这一切生意有什么意义。有些日子当我想到多萝西的星星时，它只是感觉像是好莱坞遗忘速度的一个象征。有超过2700个
names on the Hollywood walk of fame. most of them completely unknown to the 10 million people who visit every year. But other days, I take comfort in the fact that despite the pushy tour guides and snake wranglers and sweaty people in Elmo costumes, that the Walk of Fame is a place where anyone can stop, look down, and remember Dorothy Arzner, a director who made movies all the way back when. There you are. Now that's a long story, and I've breached it and said it has lots of detail.
名字在好莱坞星光大道上。其中大多数对于每年访问的1000万人来说完全陌生。但其他时候，我感到欣慰的是，尽管有爱管闲事的导游、驯蛇师和穿着艾摩服装汗流浃背的人，星光大道仍然是一个任何人都可以停下来，低头看，并记住多萝西·阿兹纳的地方，一位早在很久以前就制作电影的导演。你就在那里。那是一个很长的故事，我已经讲完了，而且它有很多细节。
Coming up after the break, what Gillian Jacobs can teach Roman Mars about Con Law? Hollywood, Con Law. So we're back with Hollywood Insider, Gillian Jacobs. Thank you so much for doing that story for us. This is a true dream come true for me. So thank you for having me. I'm delighted with the result and I'm delighted to be speaking with you now. So you're here again because of a few things we want to talk about, that's something we touched about in the main piece. But it's actually come up in the news kind of recently.
休息后回来，吉莉安·雅各布斯能教罗曼·马斯关于宪法法律的什么？好莱坞，宪法法律。我们回到了好莱坞内部人士，吉莉安·雅各布斯。非常感谢你为我们做那个故事。这对我来说真的是梦想成真。所以谢谢你邀请我。我对结果感到高兴，我也很高兴现在能和你交谈。所以你再次来到这里是因为我们想谈论的几件事，这是我们在主要部分中触及的内容。但它实际上最近在新闻中出现了。
What is that? Yeah, so when I started working on this piece with Vivian, the paramount decree felt like a sort of historical anecdote that we needed to explain to help explain the walk of fame, but it's actually become very relevant for current day Hollywood to the point where friends are actually texting me about it. And now instead of feeling like I'm boring my friends with this information I've learned working in the piece, I can actually help illuminate perhaps what we're seeing going on in
那是什么？是的，所以当我开始和薇薇安一起做这个部分时，派拉蒙判决感觉像是一种我们需要解释的历史轶事，以帮助解释星光大道，但它实际上已经变得与当今的好莱坞非常相关，以至于朋友们实际上在给我发短信谈论它。现在，我不再觉得用我在做这个部分时学到的信息来烦扰我的朋友，我实际上可以帮助阐明我们可能在
current day Hollywood. Right. And so that Paramount Decree was a Supreme Court decision from 1948. And it led to these huge changes and shakeups in the movie industry. It broke up the vertical monopoly that that studios had. Exactly. Yeah.
当今好莱坞看到的情况。对。所以那个派拉蒙判决是1948年的最高法院裁决。它导致了电影产业的巨大变化和洗牌。它打破了工作室拥有的垂直垄断。完全正确。是的。
So to recap, Hollywood during its golden age operated on something called the studio system, which meant that a very small number of very large studios dominated essentially every aspect of the American film industry. And that was that big five studios that I listened out in the piece. Exactly. So these studios operated under what you just described vertical integration, which meant that they didn't just make the films, but they had ownership and control over how they were distributed and exhibited. Right. And so the big studios, they owned the movie theaters that the films were screened in, and that meant they could simply refuse to that the films were screened in, and that
所以回顾一下，好莱坞在黄金时代运作在一种叫做工作室系统的东西上，这意味着极少数非常大的工作室基本上主导了美国电影产业的每一个方面。那就是我在文章中列出的五大工作室。完全正确。所以这些工作室在刚才描述的垂直整合下运作，这意味着他们不仅制作电影，而且拥有和控制电影如何分发和放映。对。所以大工作室，他们拥有电影放映的电影院，这意味着他们可以简单地拒绝
meant they could simply refuse to screen movies that were made by their competitors. Yes, yes, yes. So we didn't mention it in the piece, but another big aspect was that before the Paramount decree, studios engaged in something called block booking, which meant that if a movie theater was independently owned, in order to show a really popular film from a big studio It would have to sign a contract saying that would also screen a bundle of other films that were released by that studio And a lot of times those would be the not great titles that the studios wanted to unload So if a theater wanted to show the Wizard of Oz
放映由竞争对手制作的电影。是的，是的，是的。所以我们在文章中没有提到它，但另一个大方面是，在派拉蒙判决之前，工作室从事一种叫做捆绑销售的东西，这意味着如果一家电影院是独立拥有的，为了放映大工作室的一部非常受欢迎的电影，它必须签署一份合同，说它也会放映该工作室发行的一系列其他电影。而且很多时候，那些会是工作室想要卸货的不是很好的片名。所以如果一家电影院想要放映《绿野仙踪》
MGM who made Wizard of Oz could force them to exhibit like five other crappier MGM films too, and it was the paramount decree that put it into all that. It's sure to. Yes. So, the decree initiated a lot of really important and good changes to the entertainment industry. The number of independent and art house movie theater shot up from the 1950s onwards, independent filmmaking was finally able to take off the number of
制作《绿野仙踪》的米高梅可以强迫他们也放映其他五部更烂的米高梅电影，而正是派拉蒙判决结束了这一切。确实如此。是的。所以，该判决引发了娱乐产业许多非常重要和好的变化。独立和艺术电影院的数量从1950年代开始激增，独立电影制作终于能够起飞，
international films being shown, went up. Censorship was severely weakened and it kicked off a really interesting creative and freer time for American filmmaking, which is now known as the American new wave or new Hollywood. And this is where your friend your best friend friends were co-flop comes into the scene. Yes, and all these people. Okay, so let's just smash cut to the present day. And in August of 2020, the Paramount decision was actually overturned, which was pretty stunning. So why now after 70 is years that this reversal happened happen? Okay, I'm gonna state the obvious, but the film industry is so different than it was in 1948. And the rental market didn't even exist
放映的国际电影数量增加了。审查制度被严重削弱，它开启了一个非常有趣、更自由的美国电影制作时代，现在被称为美国新浪潮或新好莱坞。这就是你的朋友，你最好的朋友弗朗西斯·福特·科波拉进入场景的地方。是的，还有所有这些人。好的，让我们直接切入现在。在2020年8月，派拉蒙判决实际上被推翻了，这相当令人震惊。那么为什么在70年后发生了这种逆转？好的，我要说显而易见的事情，但电影产业与1948年时大不相同。租赁市场甚至不存在
in the 1940s when the decision was made. And in recent years, there's been a huge move into streaming content and home release. A lot of films don't even see theatrical release anymore. So the argument was that the decree wasn't relevant anymore and that studios have kind of already been in control of their distribution and exhibition with streaming. So in November of 2019, the DOJ moved to terminate the decree and in 2020, a district court judge agreed. So it is no more. What does this mean for the entertainment industry in 2022?
在1940年代做出决定时。近年来，流媒体内容和家庭发行有了巨大的发展。许多电影甚至不再进行影院发行。所以论点是该判决不再相关，而且工作室在流媒体方面已经控制了他们的分发和放映。因此，在2019年11月，司法部采取行动终止了该判决，并在2020年，一名地方法院法官表示同意。所以它不复存在了。这对2022年的娱乐产业意味着什么？
So even though the decree was terminated in 2020, there was a two-year sunset period to allow for theaters and the business model to adjust. So we actually haven't felt the full effects of the decision yet. Oh, okay. Okay. But as you can imagine, it's caused a lot of anxiety in Hollywood and the National Association of Theater Owners, the DGA and the WGA have all pushed back on this. And so why is that constituency anxious about this?
所以即使该判决在2020年被终止，也有一个两年的过渡期，允许电影院和商业模式进行调整。所以我们实际上还没有感受到该决定的全部影响。哦，好的。好的。但正如你可以想象的那样，它在好莱坞引起了很多焦虑，全国电影院业主协会、美国导演工会和美国编剧工会都对此进行了反击。那么为什么那个选民群体对此感到焦虑呢？
Okay, so we're in a period of consolidation in Hollywood right now, Warner Discovery, Disney Bot Fox. So take Disney, for example, what I think the fear is in terms of something like block booking, which is something, as I said, that the Paramount Decree Band, is that so much of the box office is motivated by huge budget films like Marvel movies. So these are the films that a majority of theaters
好的，所以我们现在处于好莱坞的整合期，华纳探索，迪士尼收购了福克斯。所以以迪士尼为例，我认为在捆绑销售方面，正如我所说，这是派拉蒙判决禁止的事情，恐惧在于票房的很大一部分是由像漫威电影这样的大预算电影驱动的。所以这些是大多数电影院
will want to screen. If studios return to the practice of block booking, Disney can theoretically tell both large and small movie chains. Okay, so if you screen Guardians of the Galaxy volume, you'll also need to screen like four direct to video quality Winnie the Pooh movies. Now I love Winnie the Pooh movies. Also shout out to Paddington movies. If you've never seen Paddington too, you're missing out. Okay, back to my main point So even if you have a larger multiplex theater chain with like 20 screens If most of those are being taken up by blocks of Disney properties and blocks of Warner Brothers properties
想要放映的电影。如果工作室恢复捆绑销售的做法，迪士尼理论上可以告诉大型和小型电影院线。好的，如果你放映《银河护卫队3》，你也需要放映像四部直接发行录像带质量的《小熊维尼》电影。现在我喜欢《小熊维尼》电影。也向《帕丁顿熊》电影致敬。如果你从未看过《帕丁顿熊2》，你就错过了。好的，回到我的主要观点。所以即使你有一个拥有20个屏幕的大型多厅电影院线，如果其中大多数被迪士尼资产和华纳兄弟资产的组合所占据
That leaves fewer movie screens left to play, you know independent and international films So this could end up hurting independent filmmaking because there's less room for it in movie theaters and despite the fact that in person viewing of movies has declined, there really is value in being able to see independent films in a movie theater. Right. And I truly love seeing a movie in the movie theater. I also like seeing them at home, but I really like the movie theater experience. So if the Paramount Decree is really set aside and all of a sudden, you know, movie studios can own theaters again in large scale. Like, what is the result of that? I don't know. I'm Hollywood insider, not Hollywood expert. Okay, so I don't know.
那剩下的电影屏幕就更少了，你知道，放映独立和国际电影。所以这最终可能会伤害独立电影制作，因为电影院里没有空间了，尽管人们亲自观看电影的情况有所下降，但在电影院观看独立电影确实有价值。对。而且我真的喜欢在电影院看电影。我也喜欢在家里看，但我真的很喜欢电影院的体验。所以如果派拉蒙判决真的被搁置，突然之间，你知道，电影工作室可以再次大规模拥有电影院。那么结果是什么？我不知道。我是好莱坞内部人士，不是好莱坞专家。好的，所以我不知道。
And that is, I think, probably why my friends are texting me. There's a lot of feelings of anxiety right now about what is the future of content. But as we know, theater owners were already seeing a decline in movie going even before this regulation was rolled back and even before the pandemic. But I think people are imagining scenarios in which one of the remaining big studios could buy AMC, which is one of the largest movie theater chains.
我认为这可能就是我的朋友们给我发短信的原因。现在对于内容的未来有很多焦虑感。但正如我们所知，电影院业主在这一法规被撤回之前，甚至在疫情之前，就已经看到了观影人数的下降。但我认为人们正在想象一种情景，其中剩下的一个大工作室可能会收购AMC，这是最大的电影院线之一。
So theoretically, that movie studio could shut out its competition and only show their properties on 11,000 screens across the country. Oh, wow. I mean, it's already pretty close to that now, but, but like, it would be bad if that were policy, for sure. Yeah. And I truly don't know if that will happen. I don't know what is going to happen. But the end of the Paramount decree came at a really scary time for movie
所以理论上，那个电影工作室可以排挤竞争对手，只在全国的11000个屏幕上放映他们的资产。哦，哇。我的意思是，现在已经非常接近了，但是，如果那是政策，那肯定会很糟糕。是的。而且我真的不知道这是否会发生。我不知道会发生什么。但派拉蒙判决的结束发生在一个对电影
theaters. It hit right in the middle of the pandemic, which decimated movie going. And there have been so many changes, even within the last few years in the industry, that it really left independent theater owners on shaky ground. And now studios have the ability to swoop in and buy up these theaters. And you know, actually, it's been quietly happening for a while. There's this weird loophole from the 1948 ruling that allowed for city-specific exceptions. So Disney already owned the El Capitan theater in Los Angeles. And in 2020 Netflix bought the famous Egyptian theater
院来说非常可怕的时刻。它正好发生在疫情期间，这摧毁了观影。而且即使在过去几年里，行业内也发生了如此多的变化，这确实让独立电影院业主处于不稳定的境地。现在工作室有能力介入并收购这些电影院。而且你知道，实际上，这种情况已经悄悄发生了一段时间。1948年的裁决中有一个奇怪的漏洞，允许针对特定城市的例外情况。所以迪士尼已经拥有了洛杉矶的埃尔卡皮坦剧院。而在2020年，Netflix收购了著名的埃及剧院
and for people not from Los Angeles. The Egyptian is an iconic LA landmark. It was actually the site of the very first big Hollywood premiere. So it has a deep history. To everything we talked about in this episode, it's right there on Hollywood Boulevard. So the Egyptian is supposed to reopen next year and half of the title screen will be Netflix. Wow. What's interesting about what you said there is that even in the Netflix theater, only 50% of the films being shown will be from Netflix. So obviously, they feel a need to assuage people's fear
对于不是来自洛杉矶的人来说。埃及剧院是洛杉矶的标志性地标。它实际上是好莱坞第一次大型首映式的地点。所以它有深厚的历史。对于我们在这集节目中谈论的一切，它就在好莱坞大道上。所以埃及剧院定于明年重新开放，标题屏幕的一半将是Netflix。哇。你刚才说的话有趣之处在于，即使在Netflix剧院，放映的电影中也只有50%将来自Netflix。所以显然，他们觉得有必要缓解人们的恐惧
about what a monopoly would mean, especially in a place so historic as the Egyptian theater. Yeah, it's been really fascinating working on this piece and seeing how cyclical this all is. You know, as it says at the National Archive, what has passed his prologue. So, you know, we are living through a historic time for the entertainment industry again.
关于垄断意味着什么，特别是在像埃及剧院这样具有历史意义的地方。是的，研究这个部分并看到这一切是多么循环，真的非常迷人。你知道，正如国家档案馆所说，过去即序幕。所以，你知道，我们再次经历着娱乐产业的历史性时刻。
And every week it feels like there's a huge breaking news story about the continued shakeout of these major mergers and consolidation of power and big, big changes happen. Yeah. But what gets me about this, and this gets me about all sorts of sort of when regulation diminishes, is there's this quote from Ruth Bader Ginsburg when part of the Voting Rights Act was being eroded. She said that getting rid of these provisions are like throwing away your umbrella in a rainstorm because you're no longer getting wet. I mean the reason why people feel that the landscape is different is because this regulation existed and now that it doesn't, it could immediately snap back to the battle days that people hate. Like, I think it's really kind of nerve-wracking.
而且每周感觉都有关于这些重大合并和权力整合的持续洗牌的重大突发新闻，而且发生了非常大的变化。是的。但关于这一点让我感到困扰的是，这让我在各种监管减少时感到困扰，露丝·巴德·金斯伯格在《投票权法案》的一部分被侵蚀时有一句名言。她说，摆脱这些条款就像在暴雨中扔掉你的雨伞，因为你不再被淋湿了。我的意思是，人们觉得景观不同的原因是这种监管曾经存在，而现在它不存在了，它可能会立即弹回到人们讨厌的糟糕日子。就像，我认为这真的让人神经紧张。
Well, thank you, Kellyanne. I really, really appreciate this. This is fun. Thank you. I'm so glad to have this forum where I can talk about this with people equally interested and not just get a glazed overlook at dinner parties anymore. Not that I go to dinner parties.
好吧，谢谢你，凯莉安。我真的，真的非常感谢。这很有趣。谢谢。我很高兴有这个论坛，我可以和同样感兴趣的人谈论这个，而不再是在晚宴上得到那种呆滞的目光。并不是说我去参加晚宴。
Well, I will be happy to talk about Dorothy Arsner with you any whole time. Thank you. Thank you. 99% in visible was produced this week by Gillian Jacobs and co-produced and edited by Vivian Le, with additional editing by Kelly Prime. Sound mixed by Martin Gonzalez, by checking by Graham Haysha, music by Swan Riau with
好吧，我很乐意随时和你谈论多萝西·阿兹纳。谢谢。谢谢。99%隐形本周由吉莉安·雅各布斯制作，薇薇安·勒联合制作和编辑，凯莉·普莱姆额外编辑。声音由马丁·冈萨雷斯混合，格雷厄姆·海沙核对，音乐由斯旺·里奥提供，
additional music from APM. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall, Kurt Colstad is our digital director. Our intern is Olivia Green. The rest of the team includes Chris Barube, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Jason De Leon, Jacob Maldonana Medina, Joe Rosenberg, Lashmodon, Sophia Klasker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Roman Coppola, Kelly Wolf, and Judith Mayn. Judith's interview didn't make it into this story, but if you want to learn more about Dorothy Arzner, you should definitely check out her book.
以及来自APM的额外音乐。我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是我们的数字总监。我们的实习生是奥利维亚·格林。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、杰森·德莱昂、雅各布·马尔多纳纳·梅迪纳、乔·罗森伯格、拉什莫顿、索菲亚·克拉斯克，以及我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢罗曼·科波拉、凯莉·沃尔夫和朱迪思·梅恩。朱迪思的采访没有进入这个故事，但如果你想了解更多关于多萝西·阿兹纳的信息，你绝对应该看看她的书。
It's called Directed by Dorothy Arzner. If you want to read more about the biz, Tyber has a substack. You can subscribe to it at Tyber's Watchlist at substack.com. Gillian Jacobs also directed a great documentary called More Than Robots. It follows four teams of high school students that they prepare for the 2021 Robotics Competition.
它叫《多萝西·阿兹纳导演》。如果你想阅读更多关于商业的内容，泰伯有一个substack。你可以在substack.com订阅泰伯的观察名单。吉莉安·雅各布斯还导演了一部很棒的纪录片叫《不仅仅是机器人》。它跟踪了四支高中生团队，他们为2021年机器人竞赛做准备。
And I know fans of 99PI will love this movie. You can watch it on Disney Plus right now. We are a part of the Stitcher & Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Reddit, and TikTok too. You can find links to other stitcher shows I love,
我知道99PI的粉丝会喜欢这部电影。你现在可以在迪士尼Plus上观看它。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上@我，罗曼·马斯，以及该节目@99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI dot org. And the winner is... Stitcher! you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及99PI的每一集过去节目，网址为99PI dot org。获胜者是……Stitcher！你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。